depuis 1928 choix tu est devenu un
classique pour ces sandwich à la viande
fumée
tout comme la file d'attenté qui s'étire
beau temps mauvais temps
on aime ça puis on a toujours aimé ça
puis c'est bon mais des habitués des
curieux mais aussi bien sûr des
touristes qui ont entendu parler de
choix du bruit pour pas cher pour le 90e
anniversaire
on affiche les prix 2009 128
bien sûr vous pouvez décider cette date
aujourd'hui au mois de novembre passé
donné un petit cadeau non réguliers dans
l'it et je pensais peut-être 80 % des
touristes et même on a dix photos avec
le notre menu passe beaucoup parlent pas
mis français ni l'anglais professionnel
moutardier proviseur le coût par johnny
donne salle baisse est là depuis 44 ans
gd tendinite au bras et à l'épaule
il maintient le rythme les clients étant
à table pour une vingtaine de minutes
seulement
j'ai commencé si j'avais 14 puis j'ai
commencé dans la cuisine qu'on plonge
heures quatre propriétaires se sont
succédé depuis le départ du fondateur
roubine choix c'est une chose qui change
de la coupe de battre le reste
exactement la même chose quand ça marche
bien on touche fois en 37 ans frank
silva en a vu des personnalités et des
vedettes comme rivaux l'instant je ne
peux pas venir chez chouette alors on va
au bella center au stade olympique c'est
toujours ça fait 80 d'essence et chose
qu'à chelsea
habituellement le même trio coûte une
vingtaine de dollars
ici à nous lisent despatie radio canada
montréal